ce soir notre performance va être
assurée par tomer sisley alors tu meurs
sisley aujourd'hui son actualité un dvd
de son spectacle stand-up
il est en tournée dans toute la france
est particulièrement 23 24 25 mars 2007
bien sûr au casino de paris
tout est bon on te remercie c'est nickel
bonsoir bonsoir
alors non merci steve j'ai une petite
question posée est ce que c'est vrai que
vous êtes français quatrième langue
vous êtes né en allemagne pour parler
hébreu
parce que votre vos parents sont
israéliens mais vous avez une petite
particularité l'un arabe l'autre juif
c'est ça vous parlez anglais et enfin
français en fait en gros tomer sisley
c'est quasiment une résolution de l'onu
tout ça ce serait en tout cas en tout
cas ça aide à comprendre les problèmes
de souvent dans plusieurs langues
différentes
alors vous avez des petits coups de
chance et des rencontres kader aoun
jamais là à vous l'avez fait rire c'est
ça alors j'ai fait rire j'ai fait rire
kader oui
ce projet fait marrer kader on s'était
rencontrés au festival de cannes en 99
et jamel en fait c'était lui qui avait
parlé de moi à kader une chance faire la
première partie de djamel mais seulement
il faut faire rire le public du schabel
la première la première partie jamel
c'était dur la première partie jamel
c'est particulièrement difficile
en règle générale c'est déjà un peu
ingrate faire la première partie de
quelqu'un
celle de jamel c'est d'autant plus
compliqué parce que jamel il a un
rapport très exclusif avec son le vie
quand le public un rapport très exclusif
avec une et en général il vient de voir
vraiment jamais les personnes d'autres
quoi alors est ce qu'on peut dire
djamel alors matière de cr9 ses droits
mais que le pape c est richard pryor
wave sur le pav praille or c'était parce
qu'il est décédé
moi c'est un noir américain plutôt les
années 70 80 et qui elle celui qui a
amené micro le micro c'est une certitude
c'est plus qu'une tradition c'est une
institution le studio le stand up ne se
pratique pas sans micro dans
l'inconscient collectif des gens un mec
qu'un micro dans la main c'est soit un
chanteur soit un animateur de
supermarché donc si tu te mets pas à
chanter c'est que tu vas parler c'est
que tu vas tu as des choses à dire et du
coup on vas tu écoutais différemment on
va tendre l'oreille à ce que tu vas nous
dire et pas ta manière de jouer les
personnages que tu va interpréter bas
c'est ce qu'on va faire ce soir mans
alors ce sera un extrait du spectacle
stand-up ce que tu va nous donner ce
soir
donc je rappelle ont tourné toute la
france 23 24 25 mars casino de paris
chômeur système on vous écoute avec un
micro voilà c'est pour vous on vous
écoute
baba bonsoir salut tout le monde
bon bah c'est ce qui me
ceux qui me connaissent voilà jeu ceux
qui me connaissent pas en tout cas je
m'appelle thomert sisley et je suis
super content on est dans cette émission
là c'est la première fois que je la fais
ça me fait un petit peu chez que ce soit
dans ce quartier là parce que mes
parents habitent vraiment juste à côté
d'ici et j'adore qu'ils soient tous les
deux en même temps dans la salle
non parce que ma mère est juive et mon
père est arabe et ils sont un petit peu
en guerre en ce moment donc
donc voilà donc donc je suis juif et
arabe à mon avis mes parents m'ont eu
uniquement bon me faire chier mais je
suis juif et arabe sais pas si vous
imaginez le nombre d'ennemis que je peux
avoir sur terre donc de personnes qui me
détestent en même temps quand même en
plus c'est pas facile d'être juifs et
arabes à ce que 50 % arabe pour un juif
c'est de toute façon déjà trop et 1%
juste pour un haram c'est juste
impensable que des problèmes et mes
parents voulaient m'appeler shlomo ben
youssouf les deux familles n'étaient pas
d'accord finalement c'est l'onu qui a
décidé
non c'est pas facile d'être vus faire
surtout en france parce que moi à chaque
fois je passe une soirée avec des
copains à qui commence à raconter des
blagues taille à deux blagues sur trois
qui ne font pas marre et encore j'ai de
la chance j'aurais pu être longue
un psycho logiquement sa main
complètement [ __ ] la tête
moi je me suis déjà jeté des pierres
aurais tu t'es relou en plus avec les
manifestations pro-palestiniennes le
samedi les manifestations pro
israélienne le dimanche [ __ ] j'ai pu
russell williams pour moi
non c'est non vraiment c'est vraiment
une situation délicate c'est dire que la
moitié de ma famille est juive et
l'autre moitié de ma famille est haram
est la dernière fois que j'ai rendu
visite à mon nom qui m'a gardé en otage
pendant six mois non c'est compliqué
serment avec tous tes conneries je sais
pas s'il faut que je sorte avec des
filles juives ou s'il faut que je sorte
avec des filles arabe
du coup sorti avec des françaises ma
dernière copine sa famille était très
française
quand ils ont appris qu'ils jettent et
ce alors fait deux mauvaises nouvelles
d'un coup je me souviens la première
fois que j'étais manger chez eux ils
étaient super gênait c'était des
racistes de base à la fin du repas ils
m'ont fouillé
non c'est vraiment des en plus
apparemment tenu le coup avec cette
copine parce que elle voulait pas se
convertir deux fois et eux et pour moi
c'était vraiment important parce que je
voulais pas choisir entre les deux
religions c'est vraiment je me suis
lancé à fond dans les deux religions
j'ai passé trois ans à traduire la tour
1 en arabe et j'ai très vite arrêté
après avec le trip religieux tout ça
parce que pas si vous vous rendez compte
mais moi si je respecte tous les
interdits de mes deux religions est le
seul truc que j'aurais le droit adverse
et boire de l'eau le mercredi soir après
une bougie et du soleil alors plus faire
shabak pendant le ramadan c'est super
chiant
voilà pas versée
non merci steve je montre la vidéo en
question comment se sert des
mini-spectacles stand up en tournée
toute la france 23 24 25 mars 2007 au
casino de paris à la console
[Musique]